bye magnus carlsen he is finishing in
second uh place here and magnus um how
are you feeling now about being done
with the preliminaries being ready for
knockouts
yeah it's um
it's uh it's fine uh i think uh today i
didn't play so so well but overall the
the performance is uh
is quite good and um
i just think um
liam was was was stronger this time in
the preliminary so i think yeah i should
be uh reasonably satisfied with uh
uh with the score and then uh we'll see
if i play yeah um liam he's played many
events now in the melted champions chess
tour what can you say about his
performance he didn't do too good in the
in the start of the tour but now he's
just crushing it
yeah that's uh
uh
that's true i think he has a style
that's suited pretty well for for rapid
chess he
uh he's
solid very very sound
and
has a pretty uh
has a pretty good technique as well so
i think i think that works um works well
um
and that's uh that's why he's uh he's
doing doing well now uh he's he's always
been very good at uh faster time
controls as well as of course being a
very
um
very decent 2700 uh player in class
school
and um we're trying to calculate who
you're going to face in the
quarterfinals magnus either
duda ding or niman who will probably
also be on 20 uh three points any
preferences
uh yeah it's usual any anybody not nan
ding would be nice
um you know i'll uh
play whoever
remember okay all right and minus what
has been the highlight for you in the
preliminaries what have you been the
most happy about with your play
uh let me uh let me see
i think i did play some
reasonable games
game with rapport was okay i guess
uh and then
um
yeah i i'm i'm you know i'm rarely very
happy with uh
with
any of any of my games but they were
reasonable but i mean clearly the
highlight of um
of uh the preliminaries is um liam's uh
performance of mine yeah
and i do know as you mentioned you do um
appreciate the beauty on the board and
and fantastic chess playing um we did
follow pragnanda's game earlier against
yodenfang forest david actually called
it one of the most beautiful games he
had seen he called a few of pragnando's
move simply genius have you
seen my game and what did you think if
so
uh no i didn't see it so far
but um i'll
be taking a look at it for sure
cool and now um knockout stage is it
nice to shift the format and the temple
a little bit to start with knockout
stage tomorrow
uh no sure um yeah when you uh
when you play these tournaments that's
always the goal to to reach there
relatively unharmed and
yeah that's
that's where the fun really starts cool
looking forward to it magnus thank you
for joining us and best of luck
thank you